epilepsy warning watch out for flashing
colors oh no how could it I can't
believe it
oh I was ready for the rest of it cereal
milk cereal oh hey how's it going this
is silly dot TIFF I literally just got
done playing some key and I knew that it
was more game suck when downloaded the
other one which is silly dot TIFF so oh
here we go and this one seung-ki had a
great time dancing last game he sure did
I remember all those dancing dances now
it's time for him to eat breakfast with
his pals I can't imagine that would go
wrong is that what happened in the last
one it was Sally dot exe cuz I can't
remember
so it's silly and seung-ki perfect
what's perfect
this isn't silly it's a amyl and mooie
oh that is definitely earthbound musica
thang for some Remax Utley okay sure
I'll follow you in there this is a ring
of marriage please seung-ki I love you
and stuff oh no wait oh yeah I forgot
okay too many ducks
Oh No DuckTales
he's got the slung key sounds of a song
key is he a sunken along Oh No
breakfast Wow
it's literally milk and cereal ha ha ha
I didn't realize it was gonna be
absolutely literal and what he said that
he was gonna eat breakfast with his pals
ok I get it
oh look it's uh people told me the name
of this one Amy uh Amy you got a little
something Amy you got a little something
right yeah that's fine whatever
all right I don't remember the name bye
it was a rabbit of some sort
rap
I am ho JP oh hi okay each other but uh
man drop a smile on me if I have find
green mother okay hotep you are
hedgehogs we know not each other but um
and Rafi smile honky ah it's a direct
port of Saladin exe that is so amazing
Oh only one more friend to feed haha oh
look it's silly silly let's go
oh oh it's a point in hmm this might
actually be actual music from the first
game which an oh I remember this it was
panic inducing because the walls were
closing in upon me please some key I
love you I love you in every way
possible in every way that would be
creepy to the Internet
I love you please no maybe oh hi oh yes
please thank you huh oh thanks hunky who
knew why I got in this box over here
directly into my mouth you say well I'm
not wanting to complain about that
chunky my love of dub dub dub okay
oh hey but I still thought that Sally
Earth Amiens summer and oh me oh Moo
Mart or more and some key anyway well
there you have it everybody Wow screw
you
cool there you go one more game left
from this developer and because I'm
obviously playing it in the wrong order
it's the first game he made mmm-hmm so
thank you everybody so much for watching
maybe I'll play that one hope you have a
good day you have a good day now you
have a good day as always in the next
one bye bye and have a good day see you
around now whoa